do you take a correspondence theory of
truth for example
uh i think that uh truth has
is defined
in
a mathematical paradigm which means it's
defined within a language and it's a
certain
value that you set
on
variables that
have the property that they can be true
or false or have a truth value that
varies in degrees
and
in some sense truth is a predicate that
you can calculate in this context
and
you can translate this into the
languages that our mind is typically
using which are models and in these
models we can have some kind of truth
definition which means that the model
depending on the type of model that you
have
can conform to any of your mathematical
tools definitions so it can be something
that is
can be reduced to a set of axioms for
instance
and this means that it can be in some
sense compressed to the set of axioms or
expanded from the set of axioms into a
certain state of that descriptive system
and
it's difficult to apply tools to
an outside world so i don't believe in
reference theory of truth these
references can only exist between
different models
on the other hand
we normally never talk about the outside
world because it's this weird quantum
graph that
is not accessible to us
and that we take to be the system that
generates patterns on our retina and and
on our systemic interface to the
universe
and
all these patterns generate models and
different
the primary one is an integrated model
of the entire universe of interception
is inspect or the perception of external
things plus proprioception right so we
in some sense have
um
a res extensor and the rest cognitions
to speak with descartes and dress
extensor is not the universe itself it's
our model of the universe it's the idea
that everything that we perceive
corresponds to a region in the same
three-dimensional space that is
dynamically changing as a temporal
extension as well and rescogins is
everything else our idea ideas that we
have about that the anticipations that
we have hypotheses that we have memories
that we have intentions that we have and
so on
and
these two interact but there are uh
several types of models that uh co-exist
in our own mind
and when we uh refer to something in the
world we refer to something in the
integrated model of the universe that we
have that is changing and it's it's not
static it's it's not reality for
instance my model of the universe
at some level contains colors and sounds
and there are no colors and sounds in
the physical universe right the physical
universe does not offer them but
colors and sounds are functions that our
brain computes to interpret certain
types of patterns in the universe